president Trump is sending the National
Guard to our southern border with Mexico
it's a dramatic step of one we've seen
before in recent history chief White
House correspondent John Roberts starts
us off tonight with the administration's
latest plan to protect the border and to
get more support for the president's
wall good evening John Chris good
evening to you President Trump is often
bragged about a dramatic reduction in
activity at the border since taking
office leading many people to wonder why
the urgency now to send the National
Guard to the border between the United
States and Mexico in the end it may be
more about applying political pressure
to get Congress to act for the third
time in recent history the u.s.
president will send the National Guard
to help secure the southern border the
Secretary of Homeland Security today
making the official announcement the
president has directed that the
Department of Defense and the Department
of Homeland Security work together with
our governor's to deploy the National
Guard to our southwest border to assist
the Border Patrol the president will be
signing a proclamation to that effect
today the deployment is expected to
begin almost immediately as soon as
tonight but its full scope is still
being worked out with the governors of
Texas New Mexico Arizona and California
while the number of troops is unclear
the rules of engagement will be similar
to operation jump start in 2006 in terms
of the operations that the National
Guard will be involved in operation
jumpstart specifically prohibited the
National Guard from laying hands under
the red state they were only in a
support capacity to the Border Patrol
are you thinking of similar rules of
engagement we're working with the
governor's we've discussed our support
activities that are very similar to
jumpstart the actual enforcement
according to Secretary Nielsen calling
up the National Guard reflects president
Trump's frustration with Congress for
withholding money for a border wall and
refusing to give him what he wants on
immigration reform Arizona Democratic
congressman Ruben Gallego an Iraq war
veteran called the deployment an insult
to our troops and tweeted for what it
would cost the guard to make just two
arrests at the border we could give a
homeless veteran permanent housing for
an entire year that brought a sharp
reaction from press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders
if that congressman's so concerned maybe
he how to show up and actually support
legislation that would fix these
problems instead of blaming the
president who's actually trying to do
something about it the White House also
saw today to allay fears of an imminent
pullout from Syria after President Trump
said last week and again yesterday he
wants to bring US troops home from Syria
soon it's time it's time we were very
successful against Isis we'll be
successful against anybody militarily
but sometimes it's time to come back
home in a statement the press secretary
said the United States and our partners
remain committed to eliminating the
small Isis presence in Syria that our
forces have not already eradicated we
will continue to consult with our allies
and friends regarding future plans but
officials tell Fox News the president
wants US forces home as soon as is
practical long-term stabilization of
Syria may be left to its neighbors
they're the ones that are at the
greatest risk so they should be stepping
up and doing more than the president's
calling on other countries to do just
that the White House today dismissed
concerns about a looming war this one
with China overtrade president Trump's
newly minted chief economic adviser
making his first appearance on the North
Lawn Larry Kudlow suggesting
negotiations may avoid tariffs before
they ever go into effect I don't think
it's a trade war I think there's going
to be intense negotiations on both sides
but look when you look at this whole
picture blame China don't blame
President Trump Trump's the solution
Kudlow acknowledge this stock market is
flushed with anxiety veering wildly on a
daily basis but the White House
seemingly unconcerned with the market's
gyrations we may have a little bit of
short-term pain but we're certainly
going to have a long-term success Kudlow
insists that there is a pot of gold and
economic growth waiting on the other end
of a recalibration of the us-china trade
relationship the question though Chris
can the president reached the end of
that particular rainbow we'll find out
John Roberts reporting at the White
House John thank you